hey youtubers it's Charlie so a lot of
craziness going on but the flash is
still on break so this bonus video is
gonna be all about big storylines and
villains I think they can do in the
future
george RR martin said this funny thing
about superhero films that we've been
seeing the last five to ten years is
that the heroes always seem to fight
villains that seem to have the exact
same powers that they do he was implying
that it might be more creative to see
the hero have to use his powers in an
unusual way to defeat the villain who
has some ability that isn't the exact
mirror of his so a really good example
is Captain Cold
his cold gun has absolutely nothing to
do with Speed Force now as amazing as
Wentworth Miller is as that character
he's a mid-level villain zoom right now
during flash season 2 is top tier and I
guess I should say spoiler warning for
everything on flash season 2 so far you
take it one step above zoom and you get
to cosmic big bads you're talking
Darkseid
you're talking anti-monitor which is why
I think because they just created the
multiverse one of the biggest stories
they could possibly do in probably one
of the final stories would draw from
crisis on Infinite Earths in the comics
now there are a couple really big
reasons why they can't do that story
right away because one we just learned
about the multiverse so they have to
explore it they have to tell the story
of all these different earths and when
you look at this picture here this is
way beyond the new 52 there are way more
than 52 earths here so this is like
pre-crisis continuity if you're a big
comic book fan if you've never read
crisis on Infinite Earths it's one of
the most famous DC big event series of
all time it happened during the mid 80s
and it was intended to be this big
summer event series but the writers also
used it to clean up a whole bunch of
continuity problems between the golden
and the Silver Age of comics there were
so many versions of characters with so
many backstories it got way too
confusing so they're like okay we're
gonna create this cosmic big bad who is
gonna kill like half of these characters
the ones that survived were the
characters with really popular comics
like Superman so they used this crisis
event to rewrite everyone's backstory
and say okay this is the new backstory
for all these characters all these other
versions they were killed off during
this big event they don't exist anymore
near the end of crisis the big villain
the anti-monitor created this giant
antimatter cannon and he was going to
use it to destroy everything that was
left so Barry in order to save them ran
so fast that he dismantled his machine
he went so fast that he just evaporated
into nothingness as if he went faster
than he had ever gone before now they
didn't explain what happened to him till
later a couple years after crisis they
retold the story of the death of Barry
Allen about how he saved the positive
matter universe by running so fast that
his molecules just evaporated into
nothingness but because the Speed Force
shares the same properties as
electricity they woven the idea of the
electrical circuit about how electricity
will travel in a circuit so Barry Allen
running super fast basically turned him
into a bolt of lightning the same bolt
of lightning that struck him and gave
him Speed Force powers so when Barry
died in this moment he became the bolts
of lightning that originally gave him
powers completing the circuit on his
life now here's where comics get really
confusing and this is why a lot of
people don't read comics all the time is
because the new 52 got rid of all that
stuff that's a really awesome story
about how Barry became the bolt of
lightning that gave him powers but
because of the new 52 technically that
didn't happen but we're talking about
comics the TV show can pick and choose
any storyline it wants to do it doesn't
have to do an exact copy of a storyline
from the comics because the metaphor of
that Barry Allen crisis story is so
amazing what I'd like to see is that the
last episode of the flash ever whether
its season 7 season 8 however long the
flash TV show ends up going that Barry
Allen sacrifices himself to save all of
his friends run so fast that he becomes
the bolt of lightning that struck him in
the first episode so that when you watch
the flash TV show when you go back and
watch it again there's this nice loop
where Barry gets struck by lightning
becomes the flash faces all these
villains makes all these friends forms
team flash then is forced to make the
ultimate sacrifice but in doing so
closes the loop on his life ensuring
that he will always become the flash and
be able to save the universe again you
can understand how the TV show might
choose to whittle away some of the
thousands of characters that were killed
off during crisis on Infinite Earths
likely it could just have a villain who
threatens the multiverse where Barry
sacrifices himself it doesn't have to be
the anti-monitor but it'd be really cool
if they could use that character
anti-monitor is way beyond New Genesis
apocalypse dark
side hi father so what I'd like to see
is just just to keep things relatable
keep the villains that Barry faces
relatively human so we're talking cobalt
blue I mean a lot of this will depend on
what the true story of zoom is they
might already be using a lot of other
beats from other speedsters so there's
maybe like one more speedster villain
that they could do like an amalgam of a
couple other different reverse flashes
but beyond that like season four season
five they're gonna have to find a big
bad like Gorilla Grodd who isn't a
speedster which is why I totally think
if they could find a way to do it
without spending all their money
gorilla grodd would be the big bad of a
future season but really this video is
just meant to explain why crisis on
Infinite Earths in Barry Allen's death
during that is an awesome way to close
the flash use that type of cosmic
villain as a big bad and a way for Barry
to sacrifice himself and close the loop
so that in the final moments of the very
last episode of the flash you know
whatever year that ends up coming in he
travels back to the very first moments
of the pilot episode let me know in the
comments though if they do a villain
that is not a speedster in a future
season let me know who you want the big
bad to be keep in mind that they'll
probably have at least seven seasons of
the flash so there's a whole lot of big
bads we're gonna have to cycle through
they've already burned through a couple
of the biggest ones like you Bart Thawne
now the hunter zolomon zoom but there
are plenty of names what I might do in
my next bonus video is explain some of
the other versions of the reverse-flash
that they could do some other storylines
for big bads and future seasons the
really easy slam dunk it's kind of
cheesy it depends on how desperate they
get for villains is they would do the
blue flash where Barry becomes an evil
version of himself that travels back in
time to try and kill him to try and fix
the past they did that during the new 52
it was an OK storyline I liked the idea
more than I liked the execution in the
comics like the idea that the future
version of Barry Allen is so torn by the
awful things that have happened because
of the way he's used his powers that he
feels his only solution is to go back in
time and kill himself so that he never
lives to damage all the people that he
loves generally speaking though each
season there's like some core idea some
core problem within himself that Barry's
trying to fix now he's trying to find
happiness this season some really
fundamental problem and that's where the
villain flows from from that idea when I
should say agents of shield is back my
video for that we'll post in the morning
and there is a new round of the DC
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video in case you guys didn't see
everyone freaking out this morning the
Game of Thrones red band trailer dropped
for season six you can click here for my
breakdown from that and you can click
here to learn about the difference
between zoom in the comics and zoom on
the TV show thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight